sand bankman freed went from a crypto
billionaire to bankruptcy the southern
district of New York has confirmed the
arrest of FTX founder Sam bankman free
in the month of November 2022 one of the
biggest Tales of financial fraud was
unraveling this is worse than Theos this
is worse than made off and it all
centered around one man and a Web of
Lies spun over the course of a few years
the devil in nerds clothing a stunning
fall from someone who is once considered
crypto's Golden Boy many out there who
believe he's just a pathological liar I
remember watching it unfold and
wondering how everyone seemed to believe
it from Wall Street two celebrities I'm
here with my boy Sam from FTX and even
Washington DC his FTX team were among
the top political donors the
multi-billion dollar class action
lawsuit accuses FTX its former CEO and
around a dozen celebrities of causing
some 11 billion dollars in US investor
losses